what is going on everyone it is axle
beats here for anime uproar and the
culling game has kicked off in full
force and it looks like we're already
getting a few of the answers we were
looking for when it comes to our new
friends hiromi and hajime if this is
going to be the pace of the entire arc
guys we are in for a wild ride before we
get into it though if you enjoy this
video and you want to see more jujutsu
kaizen content on this channel remember
to leave a like and comment down below
it only takes a second but it really
does help with the youtube algorithm and
of course if you just haven't subscribed
to anime uproar make this the video that
you do so by clicking that bell and
selecting all notifications you can also
follow anime uproar on twitter and
instagram anime uproar or you can follow
myself at excellionyt naturally this
video will contain spoilers so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned last week we saw kenjaku leading
non-sorcerers like sasuke out of the
barrier that he had set up as yuji
fushiguru hakari and panda all finally
entered them and this week we opened
with a woman in goggles scoping out an
area waiting for a signal from a kid
named amai i don't believe we've seen
either of these characters before
however we do get a few subtle clues
about am i firstly he is definitely not
having a good time right now it seems
like he's being almost held prisoner by
the woman and he's genuinely afraid of
her secondly later he says that he
recognizes yuji which if this is the
same area that sasuke was in last week
we might be able to assume that he was a
classmate of yugi's in the past before
he swallowed tsukuma's finger it's kind
of unclear if this is or isn't the same
colony though i really wish we had some
kind of labeled map to work with here
but for now that's kind of my best guess
as to why this guy might know yuji he
was friends with him in school
beforehand that said i could be totally
off though this could just be something
more central in tokyo than i believe
last time was in sendai the woman is
waiting for new players to show up and
when amai says that he just can't make
people show up out of nowhere she
threatens him leading him to apologize
profusely we finally see this close-up
image of what she looks like and i
really need to take a moment before
saying this
she has a jet pack made out of her own
hair
and like this made me laugh a decent bit
because a hair jet pack is just the
funniest thing i've ever heard of and b
if you've been watching the my hero
academia chapter reviews especially the
ones from two or three months back at
this point you know that we on the
channel have a new queen in lady nagant
who just has a very similar feeling
ability that said while i'm sure jetpack
girl is pretty great lady nagant still
has my heart we jump back to just before
yuji and fushigoro entered the game and
fushigoro is explaining that the real
dangers are going to be the incarnated
sorcerers
why does every series i talk about have
to deal with incarnations it is getting
excessive at this point either way he
goes on to explain that people from up
to a thousand years ago will likely make
an appearance and these people are
incredibly dangerous because even if
they were just from a hundred years ago
they thought about death very
differently they value death in battle
as an ultimate honor and as such they
are willing to fight to the death in a
way that yuji and fushiguro might not be
used to he hypothesizes that many of the
ancient sorcerers might have even made
deals with kenjaku specifically to meet
that end now something i want to
consider here is the location of the
cullen game zones we don't have a ton of
information on this obviously but last
chapter we saw kenjaku explaining how he
set up the zone that sasuke was in
because it was located around a nearby
execution site i had wondered last week
if that site had been where sukuna had
maybe been killed but what if it wasn't
just sukuna my thinking right now is
that these incarnated sorcerers are the
ones who had been executed in these
sites which might be a common theme
among every colony for all we know
kenjaku traveled around japan for the
last thousand years and stopped at each
great sorcerer's execution just to make
these deals with them so they could have
one more chance to live and while this
might not seem like a big thing for
these sorcerers you gotta think that
ending their story in an execution would
probably be much less appealing for them
than going out in a blaze of battle
fushiguro goes on to mention that hajime
and hiromi are possibly sorcerers just
like this now i can definitely see this
in hajime's case since he brought up
sukna a while ago but just based on
hiromi being a criminal defense lawyer
and the style of the story that his
chapter was revolving around it just
doesn't seem like he's from that far in
the distant past although maybe he had
been executed for his rampage in the
courtroom capital punishment still is
very much a thing in japan for
aggravated murderers but that's really
the only way i could see him being an
incarnation and even if that is the case
i don't see him being interested in the
idea of dying a noble death in battle so
maybe there's just something more we
don't know about either way the goal
right now is to find these incarnations
and see if they're willing to exchange
information by force if necessary and
this is where we pick up at the end of
the last chapter with the duo entering
the barrier and joining the cullen game
properly what they and we were not
expecting though is that the second they
entered the barrier they were separated
and quite literally dropped into zones
at one of nine different locations and
if you've played any online shooters in
the past especially ones with set spawn
locations you might be able to assume
that there will be spawn campers which
in this game are called beginner hunters
as yuji falls from the sky he sees amai
waving a traffic wand at him which
signals jetpack girl who launches
herself at him from a far-off skyscraper
and blasts into yuji crashing him
through a building when she is surprised
that yuji survives she calls for backup
immediately meanwhile yuji had grabbed
some of the rubble from the building as
he was being pushed through it and
throws it at her hard enough to knock
her out of the sky and causing her to
crash through a roof i'm still kind of
unclear if she's supposed to play a
nameless look how people are setting up
traps in the colony kind of role or if
she's meant to do something bigger but i
highly doubt that she's actually going
to be dealt with so easily yuji only
really has moments to think about how he
needed to ask her questions before
someone shows up and asks who do you
think you are and what are you doing to
my woman and
i gotta be honest with you if the girl's
design was a little bit strange
this guy
is just ridiculous
rather than a jet pack it looks like his
hair is being used like a helicopter's
propeller which sure why not he looks
kind of like a typical tough guy with a
vest with a shark's face on it obviously
representing how he's preying on new
arrivals but we don't really get too
much time with him as the last thing we
see on yuji's half of the chapter is am
i questioning if hanyu the jetpack girl
has been defeated as he notices haba the
helicopter man has shown up finally the
last thing that we see him say is that
he recognizes itadori as well over to
fushiguro we see that just like yuji he
is practicing true gender equality like
our lord and savior kazuma a woman is
asking why he would possibly hit her
only for him to say you hit me first
he also apparently sent nue out to look
for yuji but to no avail leading him to
believe that yuji is likely more than
two kilometers away and for our american
viewers that's about 78
740 inches or for our gamers out there
the length of 16 302 monster energy cans
stacked up on top of each other i hope
that cleared things up fushigoro goes on
to interrogate the woman about hiromi
first she tries to stop the conversation
and say how men think that women will
just obey them after they strike them
leading us to believe that she might
have had a bit of a rough past but
fushiguro quickly changes the subject
back to hiromi she offers that she could
tell fushiguro about him but in exchange
he has to become her knight which he
agrees to immediately to get the
conversation going now i am 300 sure
that this is a disastrous trap if
there's one thing i know about the
series is that the abilities are as
varied and unique as possible but they
also tend to be very strange and
agreeing to become someone's knight
could very likely be a trigger for some
kind of ability specifically one which
might force fushiguro to protect her in
general i super don't trust this girl as
it is at least with jetpack girl we
could see straightforward that she was
not trustworthy but this girl seems more
manipulative and cunning for example
using the fact that men aren't expected
to hit girls to attack people
unsuspectingly trying to guilt fushigoro
after he retaliated then only offering
information under specific circumstances
at the very least she's just not showing
all of her cards right now she reminds
him that it's a night's job to protect
her and he very coldly says that it
depends on if she's telling the truth
because he's different from yuji and if
she's lying he is more than happy to
earn the hundred points for himself now
when i say that this page gave me chills
listen we all know that fushigoro has
always been a more direct character than
yuji but the look on his face here is
brutal and savage and even the last note
on the chapter from the narrator
explains that he might be being led
towards a path of carnage i am so
excited to see this more dangerous
fujiguru in the future and honestly i'd
be surprised if he remains in this hero
role for the entirety of the series he
definitely strikes me as someone who'll
eventually be forced to walk a slightly
darker path not exactly an evil one but
more in line with maybe the punisher
where he might make a few more dark and
drastic decisions to reach his goals i
could even see him maybe being similar
to light in death note doing something
that he believes is truly good at first
but losing himself along the way but
that would be the worst case scenario
either way the woman just puts on a sly
smile and tells him to not call her you
anymore and to start calling her remy
totally unbothered by his threats and
here is where the extremely hyped
chapter comes to an end i really like
this one we got some great questions
that need answering specifically with am
i and the incarnations we saw our lads
get separated which always adds a lot of
tension we had some really fun and quick
paced action and of course we had
another hint towards fushiguro's
darkening path so much great stuff in
one chapter and i really hope they can
keep up this pace going forward but we
will have to wait and see and just a
reminder next week it does look like jiu
jitsu kaizen is taking a break so just a
heads up for that in any case though i'd
love to hear all of your thoughts on
this chapter what did you think what is
up with the incarnations and do you
think my idea of them being linked to
the execution sites is correct
furthermore who is am i and do you think
that fushiguro will eventually be forced
to start killing or just walk a
generally more ambiguously good road in
the future let me know all of your
thoughts in the comments down below if
you guys enjoyed this jiu jitsu kaizen
video and you want to see more please
leave a like and if you're new to anime
opera remember to subscribe and ring
that bell by selecting all notifications
you can help guarantee that you will not
miss any videos in the future and of
course you can always follow the channel
at anime upper on twitter or instagram
or you can follow myself at excellionyt
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our patrons over on patreon who allow
videos like this to be possible
especially the patron of legend the one
who's acknowledged by lord twego himself
alpha sigma as well are the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
clans in grata patahepha al-jatal
hinokami and water the toasted she the
spike 8227 corey mcgowan dylan isadore
spidey life tennelle tungsten tarkis
baked buddhist cody hebert and monkey d
quilly finally our pro hero tier patrons
gilgamesh the red-haired raven annel
cruz rathwind de ora very gucci alicia
octor bonnie parks joanne garcia ted
noted fat boy games and soulrise slice
and dice if you enjoy our work or maybe
think we just offer a little bit of
extra enjoyment in your day-to-day life
please consider going to patreon.com
anime uproar and supporting the channel
for as little as one dollar you will get
your name featured in future videos as
well as have access to our exclusive
patron only discord you can also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue join button next to the subscribe
option but whichever way you support us
you will get the same great benefits
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time stay excellent
[Music]
okay